歡迎收看
理財達人秀的
籌碼教學單元
歌有籌必報
我一直對這個名字覺得
取得實在太好了
好 全任小哥有這麼多的課程
他應該也覺得
這個課程名字是取得最好的
不過
不過上一次來的時候
就有提示大家小哥可能會離開我們一段時間
那今天要正式跟大家說
因為我們整個單元系列
我們整個單元系列
都已經交得非常完整
這一集小哥要跟我們
Say Goodbye
對 我們要說再見了
這一集是歌有仇必報的最後一集
大家珍惜看起來
為什麼呢
對啊 這個AI怎麼把我P的
跟安希教練一樣
我好想倒籃球
被你看起來有這麼胖嗎
這不是我吧
這三井獸吧
這AI版 這應該是你
Segu Man 我很瘦好嗎
人生相遇 至事有時
是
宋君千里 終須一別
是這樣
終須一別
幸好
後面是後會有期
幸好你應該還會上電視版吧
還會 還會
歌有酬必爆
我們今天可能就最後一集了
因為歌這邊說實話
對我們幫忙也很多
因為小哥有很多種課程
有文字的
也有線上直播的
有非常非常多種
那我們這邊說真的太佛心
每次都資料準備很多
然後榮耀班只收一點點錢
這樣子
對
那也交完了
交得差不多了
該買籌碼K的也都買了吧
是不是要該附上我的連結
好 宣傳一下
小哥的籌碼K很好用
所以我們要說再見
今天特別跟各位講
在建的股票
其实在建就是不建
在建就是不建
在建后面其实还有一些状况
我们也可能会旧情复燃
真的吗
所以下次可能在某个地方看到我们
又相遇了
在建它有分波段涨势再起
还有烫手山域
那这个你就要分手快乐
又要唱另一首了是不是
赶紧分手
敬余节
分手快乐
祝你快乐
大放送今天
好
那再见两种
我们来看一下
坏的再见
坏的再见有高档出货
关键高档主力大卖
那种赶快说再见
另外好的再见
关键低档买
或是低档主力买
低档进货
那波段再现
一见就开心
这一种是真的再见面了
我们又见面了
开心
搞不好过了几年
我们又再见面了
然后呢
又再开
哥友仇必报
认不出彼此的变形了
变形
我还以为你说变形了
我应该不会再变形了
这个就差不多了
没可能变瘦
对 可能变瘦
对
好
所以再见股从而怎么观察呢
好的再见呢
它有几个特点
第一个股价在低档
或是主头买进
或是关键分点买进
那坏了再建
第一个股价在高档
主力卖
散物卖
急保护数增
然后关键分点在大卖
那我们今天举了非常多的案例
是
来给各位看
好
来看一下
还记得
先好的还坏的
好的
先好的
我们都先讲好的
先吃甜甜
先吃甜的
我們在這個去年的時候
去年的時候
因為淵末也在去年這個時候
那時候呢
大約在冬季
一直在講這個三寧是見頂
是的
因為見頂在那時候
殖率真的超高
它一直都是PCB裡面的極優升
對
那時候殖率有7%
那有個特定分點
假如你常關注我的話
你大概就知道是哪個分點
就離公司蠻近的
離公司蠻近的
在桃園
離小哥家可能也不遠
不遠不遠
開車18分鐘
因為以前我在那邊上班
是不是你在那裡下單
你趕快承認
對對對
還真的以前在那邊開過步
好啦 這個特定分點在低檔
我們來看一下
在80幾塊的時候
80幾塊 90幾塊
買的超多
那買超多
各位看一天買一兩百張
一兩百張很多
因為這行股票
這個一兩百張
也要800多萬到1000多萬
也蠻多的
每天買這麼多又在第一檔
第一檔你看到買這麼多
你就記得趕快進場
那時候我們還特別把它編入
我們自製的ETF裡面
外面很多ETF
我們自己也自製一個ETF
有嗎?你有跟我講嗎?
有啊 叫08888ETF
有有有有 有大家去查一下
我記得了
說0888你才記得對不對
林伯發發發08888ETM08888ETF見頂就是我們一個很重要的成分股是因為那時候呢
這個低檔關鍵買高值利率
那後面呢
你要爆了一年到現在
見頂漲了兩倍半
對
漲了兩倍半 漲很多
那最近在高檔
其實特定分點已經獲利了結了
這標題下錯了嗎
這根本就是壞的再見股
我們講的是
之前好的再見
我們先講點歷史
在這個地方是好的
連最後一集都要這樣繃緊神經
在注意你
最近才變壞
要算是比較認真
最近變壞了
要認真點
我們說之前在這裡好的時候
因為我要講點歷史的事件
就是曾經它很好
曾經很好
最近變得比較差
接下來呢
這個也是我們歌有酬必爆
各位你可以去查一下
第四集还是第五集
这应该已经有两年的历史了
没有没有
这已经三年了
快四年了
我们这个单元这么久了
我们2020年1月底开播的
刚好迎接了COVID-19
迎接COVID-19的下山
刚来的时候还没有戴口罩
后面就要戴口罩了
在COVID-19之前
我印象很深刻
我们两个又活过来了
我在FB里面打卡
所以每年都会把我回顾
三年前你在做什麼
我看到三年前抱著哆啦A夢跟趙華拍照
而且那時候我們還PK體重
說每個人要減幾公斤
你沒有達到
你還記得
三年來我的體重始終如一
我瘦了3.5公斤
我大概從高點算起來
我大概瘦1公斤
三年來瘦1公斤
一年平均瘦300克
緩跌緩跌
姐妹怎麼這麼懶
好了
那好 再見股
這個2023的夜輝
各位看一下
這就是我們剛開播的時候
我們那時候特別講這個案例
講說7塊多的夜輝
高雄人
對 高雄人
買不停
你看好的再見股
你看高雄人大買
然後後面整個噴出
不過這個高雄人搞很久
真的搞很久
真的 對一般觀眾來說
覺得怎麼兩禮拜
三禮拜沒漲就在叫了
對啊 結果你看
人家抱多久
人家大概爆了一年半
那这个钢铁股就跟这个航运股走了一段
夯海王钢铁人
在那时候很火红
你各位看一下
低档到高档
这几倍
5倍
钢铁这种各位数价钱的涨起来真的吓人
对 5倍
最近他们也蠢蠢欲动
可以看看
因为也休息了一年半了
对 也休息一段时间了
好 你要来唱球了
对不对
是不是
近期好的戰艦谷 這個我們也一直講啊
講到大家就覺得小哥 你有沒有別的好講
有沒有看到 有沒有
最近他噴出了 他動了
對 最近我學員他說出國都要靠可塵
因為他可塵 他就一路爆 一直爆
我也始終如一 搞很久 對 搞很久
最近已經開步領延上軌了
這個也是低檔關鍵大買
那關鍵大買反正你抱要有耐心
因為好像地緣性分點
他們真的會搞一兩年
對 他們買很多 買超多
等到高檔你看到利多新聞
在想上冊的時候
這個地緣分點可能都想賣了
因為前兩天也有人留言給我
就一直問可乘
然後說他業績不好啊
年月雙減很嚴重啊
我說這檔請不要看業績
我們哪有在 誰給你看營收啊
這檔看業績看不懂
我們看的是存款好不好
我們這禁止就230塊了
你知道嗎
然後還問我說
股力會不會發不出來
我說現金多到這樣的公司
發不出來也是蠻奇怪
你怕什麼
12月再發5塊給你
好不好
你有看過年終發一次
年底再多發5塊的嗎
對 我知道錢太多了
錢真的很多
所以最近搞不好是
這個除菸強請的滿身
有可能
不過最近漲得也超過這個佩琪
好 漲得也差不多到小哥
有評估說差不多的那個
整數關卡
最近真的是蠻猛的
好 這個是做鍵盤的
接下來講這個
也是近期好的債劍股
2387的金元
你還記得金元在哪個位置嗎
我不記得了耶
我只知道他做鍵盤
而且是什麼剪刀腳鍵盤
對
我覺得那個財經節目真的很會找題材
那個時候呢
我們講金遠在哪裡
我們先講金遠在哪裡
金遠他就位在台中市
稍微偏北一點點
對
偏北一點
北屯攤子那邊
北屯
那北屯攤子那邊各位看一下
你只要看到低檔
這個北屯再買
後面很容易漲一段
那前幾天低檔他又買又漲一段
可是這邊不是在賣嗎
為什麼賣還漲
他買完之後賣一段
稍微修正一下
這邊又買
這邊又買我就覺得有點奇怪
我覺得還蠻猛的 漲上去就賣
對 怎麼這裡又買
欸 結果法索會
這邊又漲 厲害厲害
我特別愛這種特別愛這種這個有效率雖然漲幅沒有很大但至少有效率他真的有效率他只要買就很快要發動
買沒多久至少就動一下
那賣一賣呢
賣一賣就會開始跌
我們特別愛這種
北屯人比較急
北屯人比較短
北屯人講求效率
我們不能再講太多
北屯人來留言
說我們什麼比較急比較短
高雄跟台南人搞很久
對啊
這樣子我下去台中
我也有危險
好 來看一下
這也是近期好的再見湖
這2492的華星科
我懂
這個就在我們公司附近
對對對
你啊你啊
公司附近有一條路
對
補習班林立的
旁邊
這個名字很好聽
管錢
管錢各位看一下
他在八九十塊也是買一堆
買一堆
那都沒賣
最近也是拉到127高點
所以他也算近期好的在建股
還不錯
而且這一家我們講那麼久
他都不換分點
也算有情有義了
那個業員都已經
都已經快要退休了
還換
你叫一個快要退休的人
還要換公司嗎
他們都已經合作很久了
都已經有感情了
不大會隨便換
因為很多人都會說
你們這個節目
把人家分點都講出來
以後他就跑掉了
Sorry 我們講他很多次 他還在
講四年了
他還在
講四年了 不換就不換
這個說換沒那麼容易
愛跟就跟啊
對啊 波段的啊
看你玩得過我還是我玩得過
對啊 我就賭你抱不住啊
對不對
誰跟小哥一樣
可曾可以抱三年
世紀大腰股出現了
這個要特別講一下
好的再見
這個比較特別
這個沒有關鍵分點
那他是散步拱上來的嗎
我知道有頭顧老師非常喜歡他
他比較特別的是
他也是修正了一段時間
然後在低檔
有一次我在做功課的時候
我就發現
他居然是低檔主力買
低檔主力買
就是這個殺下來
所謂的主力不是關鍵分點
不是
低檔主力在買超
就突然出現它
那會出現在低檔主力買的股票
大部分都在年限以下
因為我們低檔主力買
我們只挑10檔
然後我們是從
官邻年限排序的
所以大部分挑都在這個年限以下
那時候出現它
就怪怪的
怎麼會出現它
就出現的時候在這個位置
那各位來看一下
一檔主力買有個特色
它的年限可能還在往下走
但是它有一條線即將翻揚
這條線叫做月線
所以月線假如即將翻揚
主力又買的話
那這種很有可能會大漲一波
這一檔真的是神妖級的
它最高有到快500塊
400多塊下來的
而且這過程中
它是沒有賺錢的一家公司
他轉到400多的時候
半導體業的朋友就告訴我
今天大放送 因為最後一集嘛
就說我告訴你啦
我都查過他在台藝電下的經緣了啦
那個經緣量是不會賺錢的
真的就是完全沒有辦法賺錢的
好 就只能說到這了
可是主力要買就是要買 對
然後後來就真的跌下來了 對
因為真的就沒有賺錢啊
大家去看他的EPS
那這個500塊到
這個不到100塊也打兩折了
對 很誇張
死貓也會跳一下
最近一跳又漲100多%囉
那這種比較特別的各位
你有興趣的歡迎關注
小客的交易筆記本
10月29號我們這邊
歸零年限我們就排戲了
來來來來
各位看一下最近這幾個
像這個經歷科
他就是這個漲了一大段
對
那最近呢
這個各位你也可以多關注一下
反正這幾個都是在年限以下
在當時年限以下的標的
那這是一個月前做的功課
那各位你可以多多觀察一下
因為一個月前
這些股票的籌碼當然不錯
等於是說
可能可以看一下
誰還沒有大漲對不對
好
你可以去找一下
這裡面有
看有的也漲30-40%
那經歷科是最誇張
有我有興趣的
好 沒事
有你有興趣喔
真的喔
要不要暗示一下
暗示一下 幾個字
私底下在聯絡
私
沒有問到
好啦 以上呢是好的再見
你要讓我再解釋一次
這東森跟我們東森電視沒有關係喔
所以我們要特別講一下
壞的再見股
不要再問我他長什麼了 我不知道喔
對 那波一直漲上來
跟著航運股漲上來啊
對
這個明明就是假航運真直銷嘛
對啊 人家二六開頭的
尊重一下航運股
不過他已經沒有編在航運裡面
他曾經有航運事業
他曾經有
後來就變成購物跟直銷了
那這個東升你看
這段很急 漲了五倍那漲五倍之後主力開始賣特定分點大賣那後面70塊呢就整個跌回來所以呢當你在高檔看到主力賣
然後呢
特定分點賣
你要趕快出脫
因為你看70塊跌回來
哇
你沒不了解
那很痛
我覺得大家可以去查一下
那段時間他的新聞
就在漲的時候
除了他還會提到
他自己以前一些航運的東西以後
告訴你
他可是疫情下的電商概念股呢
電商
我每次上課的時候
舉手調查一下
你有買過兩個字一樣
XX購物
就兩個一樣的
舉手
我們就很多人舉手
你有買過XX的
大概一半人舉手
你有買過這個
很少人舉手
可是他鍋子賣得很好
有一段時間電視購物的鍋子
賣得嚇嚇叫
所以就覺得
長上來真的是有人在跑
我們這是公開版
我們講這麼多
感覺上會被滅口
先被北屯人滅了
再被動
另外一個我們總複習一下
這也是常提到他
也是在高檔你看
關鍵賣 主力賣
對啊
假百貨
假航運真百貨
百貨公司
那剛好主力賣 關鍵賣
你看後面也是跌一段
也是打了三折不到
好 我怎麼覺得講到這邊
其實都是壞的
每一個好的
我們最近講壞的
那最近呢
最近喔
這講的比較近一點了
各位看一下3308連得
它也是漲一段喔
而漲一段在高點
大概68塊附近
主力也大賣囉
後面68塊附近一下跌
各位看 跌到最低也跌到
這個30幾塊
一下子也打5折
很快喔
這個跌下來很快
這不到半年耶
很驚人
立馬五折
這檔幹嘛我都不知道
跟那個夏莊一樣
連做什麼的我都不清楚
你看夏莊到了冬天立馬打五折
這檔你一定手拉
銀邦
3693的銀邦
前陣子也是很火紅的
可是說實話人家是有EPS的公司
只是本益比真的太高了
而且你看高檔642
你看高檔的時候
主力也大賣
那後面642呢
也是回檔一段
也是打了大概7折
所以呢
高檔你看到主力賣
散戶買
就是容易回檔
那這種就是會在我們的
高檔所有股裡面
來 接下來是這個
3583的新雲
我們今天是決定
把上市貴公司都得罪一輪
是不是
沒有 我就之前
之前
我們公開版都講歷史的
什麼產業都掃一遍
你現在要我怎麼做下去
講歷史的嘛
就歷史在高檔主力賣嘛
你講你講怎麼樣了
這檔怎麼樣了
歷史高檔主力賣
所以你要跑啊
各位看266高檔
一下就殺到200以下
所以高檔主力賣呢
都是一種危機啦
不過我覺得它在半導體
還是有它一定的產業地位啦
對
可能短線長太多啦
是
修正一下可能還會再上去啦
對啦
公司不要來告我
等筹码轉好
要告你應該不是星雲
是前面的人
好 來 接下來
你幹嘛又要來 為什麼再來
因為他是近期壞的在劍
不是你到底要鞭詩幾次
他剛剛那個觀眾沒有專心看
跑去買劍頂了
跟你講說近期他主力
這關鍵是轉賣的
你要小心一點
要專心一點
這是近期轉壞的
就是本人對見頂絕對沒有其他的想法
純粹發表一個不自殺的聲明
我們純粹看籌碼啦
陳怡的一哥你有一間
有有有
各位來看一哥
一哥高檔這特定分點是大賣
你看那時候快600的
我知道這個在哪裡
這個在迪化街那裡對不對
對
你知道嗎
這個時候還有法說會
還有法說會
老闆還去講你知道嗎
老闆講的時候底下法院都說
哇塞 羅永真的是還滿不錯的
然後底下的法蘭還切勢於
那個是我朋友在法蘭間告訴我的
他說 據他們的經驗
就差不多了
就去西門町走走
看看那裡的分店
因為這個也是壞的債見股
你看高檔有特定分店賣
你就要小心一點啦
好 怎麼講了半天
大家就想說
小哥舉的是現在都叫你不要碰的
好 因為歷史經驗我們可以學起來
也沒有都叫你不要碰
只是這些公司近期上面
籌碼都是已經轉換
或者是並沒有明顯的買盤進駐
是教您怎麼看
過去它的關鍵分點
或者主力在低檔大買的時候
後面確實都伴隨的一波漲幅好
所以重點來了
今天雖然是最後一集
還是有榮耀班
而且榮耀班超級重要
小哥把近期关键分点
主力大户
第一档之货
可以观察的股票
都在荣耀班一档一档来解说